though Western beauty standards may be
taking the world by storm they still
aren't the norm everywhere there are
some cultures that take their beauty
standards seriously and sometimes it can
seem a bit brutal if you were a
first-time viewer click that red
subscribe button prepare to be shocked
with these 10 unusual women beauty
standards around the world double
toothed Japan most of the time when
people have crooked teeth in Western
cultures they pay thousands of dollars
to get them fixed the exact opposite is
true in Japan where women pay to have
their teeth crooked
this beauty standard is known as Yaiba
which translates into double tooth in
Japanese the trend started with Japanese
pop stars but women with crooked teeth
have been thought to be alluring in
Japan for a while long earlobes Masai
tribes of Kenya the mastoid tribes of
Kenya have been stretching their
earlobes for centuries the older the
person is the longer their earlobes tend
to be the Maasai women stretch their
earlobes over time with various sized
horns
rocks or sticks once they are done with
the stretching process they decorate
their earlobes with beaded ornaments
stretched lips southern Ethiopia when a
girl is becoming a woman in this
southern Ethiopian tribe they will start
the lip stretching or lip plating
process over a period of time she and
her family will keep stretching her lips
until it is about 8 to 20 centimeters in
diameter at that point the woman will
put a plate in her lip what she takes
great pride in decorating the process is
also important as it is a part of
wedding rituals in their culture
elongated necks Thailand from the time
they are 4 years old the women of the
cayenne tribe in northern Thailand start
putting brass coils around their neck as
the woman ages she gets more and more
coils eventually the coils elongate
their neck which is considered beautiful
in their culture though it seems like
they are growing long necks it's
actually the weight of the coils pushing
their shoulders down that gives the
illusion of answerable long necks fat
farms Mauritania in the Western cultured
world it's hard to believe that people
would actually send their young daughter
to fat farms to pump them up that is
exactly what they do in Mauritania where
being curvy and having stretch marks are
most desirable girls are sent to camps
where they're force-fed up to 16,000
calories a day all
the sake of being able to get married
red clay skin and hair and the people of
northern Namibia the Himba people of
northern namibia fly themselves head to
toe in a thick lake called ocean The
O'Jays is made from ochre fat and
aromatic resin when applied to the hair
and body it turns everything in orangish
red which is supposed to symbolize blood
to the Hindu people blood is the essence
of life while this is a beauty standard
it actually serves a second purpose the
arches also helps protect your skin from
the Sun and heat scarification
Ethiopia's karo tribe the ancient ritual
of scarification in Ethiopia's karo
tribe seems a bit brutal but it's still
practiced today it is a long painful
process that includes women cutting
patterns into their faces and chests
with sharp objects like glass or knives
once the wounds are open the women rub
charcoal or gunpowder into the openings
so that the wounds will form keloids
once they heal over a period of time
women can add more and more scars to
themselves they think of scars as
artwork and admit that the only reason
they still perform scarification is to
attract men face tattoos Maori the Maori
of the indigenous Polynesian people of
New Zealand and have a rich and
interesting culture Maori men and women
have been using face tattoos or facial
moko to enhance beauty show social
status and show personality for
centuries no to facial moko are alike
and women usually have a less extreme
version than their male counterparts
Maori women usually get facial moko on
their chins and they believe this
defines and flatters the face draws
attention to the eyes and can even
correct facial flaws surgical bandages
Iran when it comes to beauty standards
around the world most cultures agree
that noses are important but none of
them take it as far as women in Iran
which has now become the nose job
capital of the world Iranian women are
born with what they believe are
unflattering noses so when women are old
enough they get them fixed to them
wearing their surgical bandages from
their nose jobs are like wearing a
bandage of honour women will even fake
getting nose jobs and wear fake surgical
bandages all for the sake of being
desired teeth filing Indonesia in
Indonesia it is customary for boys and
girls to go through Matata or teeth
filing by the time they hit puberty this
makes the teeth look elongated and sharp
and is considered quite beautiful in
their culture
the custom is said to help the soul
remove sadistic urges like jealousy and
anger while people don't have to get it
done exactly at puberty it is a custom
that must be done before someone can get
married what did you think of these
unusual beauty standards for women
around the world react in the comments
section below and don't forget to like
this video and subscribe to the things